[Musica]
quando avevo quattro anni se ero il più
grande costruttore di automobili come
vedete questo andava velocissimo solo
che i miei genitori non mi hanno
insegnato a costruire motore a scoppio
con la carta igienica quindi avevo delle
difficoltà quando poi avevo sei anni
volevo volevo diventare un inventore ero
ispirato da archimede il personaggio del
topolino che che conoscete e otto anni
invece ho scoperto litro mentre forse le
conoscete è un insetto che ha le gambe
così sottili che non comunque la
superficie dell'acqua breve costruire un
libro m a robot sono che tutti i miei
prototipi andavano a fondo perché erano
di ferro e poi non sapevo scrivere il
codice di questo robot è ok questo è un
sogno forse un po stupido però provate a
pensare a i vostri sogni che avevate da
piccoli perché poi lo chiederò a
qualcuno di voi si è finalmente a 11
anni arriva questo spettacolo di
plastica un pentium ii 350 magari con il
quale finalmente sono riuscito
realizzare mio primo sogno ho costruito
un automobile sei mesi a sviluppare
questo questa automobile
ma che mi diceva ma perché non c'è
giocare con i bambini come tutti gli
altri che non ho mai visto costruendo un
automobile e volante risultato
ok vabbè però si muove esce anche 1 min
io penso che possiamo fare un salto nel
tempo e andare nel 2009 avevo 22 anni ho
aspettato per qualche giorno di fila per
più volte voglia dire in sala d'attesa
del prelievo del sangue con il numerino
in mano però avuto una visione
nessuno avrebbe più dovuto aspettare in
sala d'attesa con il numerino in mano e
così quell'anno con un amico abbiamo
brevettato un algoritmo per prevedere i
tempi di attesa e da lì abbiamo
costituito una società abbiamo creato un
software è tuttora questo sistema è
attivo nelle sale d'attesa di diversi
ospedali una settantina gli ospedali e
in otto anni l'hanno utilizzato 550mila
persone che quindi facendo un rapido
calcolo con la media dei tempi di attesa
risparmiati sono state risparmiate
660mila ora in coda che sono 75 anni
quindi parlando di tecnologia che ti
permette di realizzare sogni quanti
sogni si possono realizzare in 75 anni
di 75 anni in tempo
da lì oggi siamo una quarantina di
ragazzi per sviluppo software e voi
pensate forse che lo di sviluppare
software sia una cosa noiosa un po
alienante forse l'immagine che voi avete
di un sos turista è è questa
una persona che continua a scrivere cose
incomprensibili sul monitor che non va
disturbato che sta delle ore al computer
e noi ci appassioniamo tantissimo di
questi problemi noi lasciamo stare per
dei giorni su tre righe di codice e come
facciamo a fare questo perché siamo così
strambe lo facciamo perché noi non
stiamo scrivendo un software noi stiamo
mettendo insieme delle informazioni e
mettere insieme informazioni è l'unico
modo per realizzare il sogno
so che potrebbe essere considerato
eccessivo anche perché io sono di parte
però vi dimostrerò che con la tecnologia
si possa realizzare
tantissimi i sogni come in realtà
abbiamo già sentito oggi ad esempio
stiamo installando al gemelli di roma
dei bisogni in realtà virtuale per
accompagnare i numerosi up e di altri
che i bambini e gli adolescenti nelle
loro sedute di terapia e questo è
sicuramente un modo per farli evadere da
quel da quel momento ma ci sono tanti
altri modi con cui si possono emozionare
e emozionare le persone quindi quella
cosa che sembra un codice sterile in
realtà a questo risultato sulle sulle
persone a questo effetto
[Musica]
ma in carne sembrava di stare veramente
di ceramica di monreale si avevo le
vertigini
[Musica]
trapanesi c'è un sacco di roba
perché no perché c'è un po di giri
ritengo perché io soffro di vertigini e
allora queste linee rispetto che avrei
fatto
mentre dire non farci incolpati non
pensavo di video della loro
deterioramento fantasmi questo ragazzo
sta guardando un oscilloscopio lo può
guardare per sei mesi alla ricerca della
frequenza perfetta e il suo mettere
insieme informazioni il suo creare
collegamenti realizza cose di questo
tipo
questo signore è malato di parkinson
la sua vita è sicuramente influenzato da
questa stessa sindrome che c'è un modo
che stanno scoprendo in queste settimane
per diciamo che se c'è intervenire sul
sistema nervoso
[Musica]
ma se facciamo ci sorge lessi musica
the sun times niente shopping oppure con
un apparecchio acustico questa ragazza
di 29 anni riesce a sentire la sua voce
con la prima volta ci sono cose anche un
po più un po più leggera anche se questi
volumi sembrano molto pesanti
sapete chi è questa persona margaret
hamilton
lei sta reggendo il suo codice che ha
scritto un software stampato a il tempo
si stampava il software non so per quale
motivo ma forse bisognava rimanere
legati alla carta in qualche modo è più
alto di lei
lei è una piccolina ma realtà è una
grandissima ingegnere del software ha
permesso all apollo di andare sulla luna
e lei ha coniato il termine software
engineering quindi ore e ore ore ore ore
di dedizione sul codice hanno realizzato
il sogno dell'umanità
io penso che il modo in cui la
tecnologia ci aiuta a realizzare i
nostri sogni e creando dei collegamenti
l'abbiamo già detto è è fondamentale
creare dei collegamenti tra una persona
e un'altra persona
oltre a una persona è un'informazione
quando tu entri in contatto con un'altra
con informazione con una persona le tue
regole del gioco cambiano
tu hai una visione completamente diversa
in diverse priorità e ai grassi punto di
vista sono così che
quando tu crei collegamenti che si
creano nuovi mondi dentro di tre quando
tu vedi il mondo da un punto di vista
diverso anche il mondo cambia e quindi
il mondo inizia in qualche modo a
lavorare a collaborare per farti
realizzare i tuoi sogni
pensate in questo modo gli artisti
possano immaginare dei mondi che non
esistono
questa persona si è immaginato un cane
che vive sopra la propria cuccia che è
super appassionato di aeroplanini e non
vede l'ora di riprendere il volo e ci
sono persone talmente folli da
dimenticarsi che questo è un mondo
surreale e realizza il suo sogno ma
fatto potete è un testo del genere
portobello ex minuti che finalmente
riesce a volare sulla sua cuccia che si
guarda intorno anche
[Musica]
io potrei raccontarvi 200 storie su come
la tecnologia ha aiutato a provare a
realizzare i sogni delle persone ma nata
con il nostro team
abbiamo pensato qualche qualche tempo fa
di darvi la dimostrazione che questa
cosa succede davvero
e quindi abbiamo preparato un sistema
per raccogliere vostri sogni e magari
realizzarne qualcuno qualcuno questa
sera quindi io vi invito a quel che in
realtà è ancora mattina io vi invito a
visitare questo sito dal vostro telefono
qualcuno dovrebbe avere essere riuscito
ad avere accesso al wifi ne leggo
qualcuno se vi interessa perché sono
sono curiosi c'è giulia che sognava di
fare la scrittrice
insomma c'è tommaso che ha un partitone
di boc correttori di bozze quindi magari
si potrebbero mettere in contatto e
iniziare a scrivere un libro assieme
oppure c'è alberto che sognava di fare
il fumettista e in sala c'è valeria che
di professione fa ha registrato ice dei
libri per bambini e anziani potrebbero
creare dei nuovi personaggi magari come
hanno fatto per snoopy poi c'è marta che
da piccola sognava di costruire un razzo
spaziale per portare a spasso il suo
peluche e non so come aiutare forse i
ragazzi di zucchetti hanno creato il
razzo cosmo che potrebbero darle darle
una mano
quindi grazie a te che noi ci abbiamo
messo in relazione a tutti i vostri
sogni tutte le vostre attività e e si
può fare un passettino piccolo verso la
realizzazione
di queste vostre aspettative i sogni
sono sono super importanti dobbiamo con
tanto tenere a mente perché immagino che
quando vi ho chiesto di pensare al
vostro non fosse così chiaro subito
dietro l'angolo ci avete dovuto pensare
quali fossero questi sogni e
ricostruirli dovete portando avanti
mettendovi in connessione con le persone
conosco un'altra persona che aveva un
sogno è che il suo mestiere a ha creato
un'opera d'arte e ci siamo chiesti come
la tecnologia avrebbe potuto aiutarla a
realizzare il suo sogno del suo sogno
era quello di parlare nel mondo dei
vostri sogni e oggi debbie ha la
possibilità di realizzarlo
[Musica]
più
no
[Musica]
[Risate]
io
[Musica]
via
gestire
[Musica]
[Applauso]